راح نبدا اذا مشاهدينا من الخبر اللي نكمل
معانا من ايام الامير هاري مذكراته
ومقابلاته فما زال اسم الامير هاري
ومذكراته سبيرز متصدرين الاخبار والعناوين
وان كان بسبب الفضائح والقنابل والمفاجاه
الي فجر عن العائله الملكيه واللي فضح
الدنيا فيها بصراحه
وبالجديد اليوم هو تصدر الكتاب قائمه
الكتب غير الروائيه الاكثر مبيعا في
المملكه المتحده وايضا تحقيق رقم قياسي
ببيع اكثر من 400,000 نسخه من المذكرات
سواء كانت ورقيه او الكترونيه او صوتيه
واكدت دار النشر المشرفه على طباعه الكتاب
نشره انه كانت تتوقع انه الكتابه واسع لكن
اللي صار انه مبيعات فقط وتجاوزت التوقعات
بكثير وفي مشهد لفه الحقيقه واثار تفاعل
كبير من الصاج وطريقه عرض مكتبه بريطانيه
لا نسخ مذكرات الاميره
مع شايفينها امامكم المكتبه عرض الكتاب
على الرفوف وبينهم حطوا روايه للمؤلفه بلا
ماكي بعنوان هاو تو كلير فاملي او كيف
تقتل عائلتك
يعني كله رمي حكي بس يعني بطريقه مدروسه
بطريقه العرض خاصه مع الفضائح اللي فضحها
وفجرها في هذا الكتاب المكتبه ما اختفت
بعرض الكتب بهذا الشكل بس همم ولكن قالت
انه عندنا نسخ احتياطي كثير من كتاب
احتياط لهاري يعني كمان لعبه ثانيه من
المكتبه على اسم الكتاب صراحه ثانيه عندهم
فريق تسويق شكله تعبان في التفكير بالعصر
الدهني وما عنده افكار جديده عموما اسلوب
العرض هذا انتشر حول العالم وتم تداوله
بشكل واسع بس مين نشر الصور واثار
الاهتمام يا ترى الاميره
عهد اليونان واللي نشرت الصوره على
انستغرام من دون اي تعليق لكن ليش عمال
يقول لكم انه اعاده تنشرها على الصوره كان
لافتت الاجابه هي لانه ببساطه الامير
وليام هو الاب الروحي او
الجعد فاذر زي ما بيسموه بالانجليزي
الاميره
على كل حال على سيره التعليقات وردود على
المذكرات فما زالت القصر ملتزم الصمت وما
في اي رد رسمي تم تداوله لكن في معلومات
متداوله اليوم انه كامله زوجه الملك تشارج
اللي تكلم معناها هاري في مذكرات ووصفها
كمان اذا بتتذكروا بالشريره والخطيره وقال
انه هو واخوت وصل وابوهم علشان ما يتزوجها
المعلومات بتقول انه كامله مصابه بالذهول
والصدمه من اللي سمعته وانه هاري عمي
دمرته انه الكتاب في الكتير من الانتقام
من العائله الملكيه وانه لو انه الملك راح
للزفت كانت لسه عايشه باللي في المذكرات
لكانت مدمرت تماما